foreign
[Music]
this is famous for where we explore
luxury travel from the locals in the
know Hokkaido is in
I'll need these
[Music]
is the northernmost of Japan's four main
islands and covers a fifth of the
country I'm heading deep into tokachi an
area known for its agricultural land
where locals are turning farming upside
down in pursuit of sustainability and
creating the world's most expensive
mango along the way
[Music]
I feel like I should be in a tropical
Paradise somewhere but we're in the
middle of Hokkaido the snow country
um that's so good
[Music]
um
iki's brand of mangoes sell for up to
230 bucks each depending on the size and
his daughter helps package them up
what makes these mangoes so valuable
comes down to how they're grown using
resources found in nature like snow and
Onsen Hot Springs
[Music]
then during the colder months hiroyiki
uses Onsen heat to warm up the
greenhouse and produce a traditionally
tropical fruit even in Winter without
any pesticides
motivation
[Music]
next up we head to a skiers Paradise
niseko Resort it's known for getting the
most natural snow in the world at a time
when other places rely on artificial
powder some even call it the Aspen of
the East here almost 30 lifts zip across
these interconnected trails
pretty awesome
the area typically gets twice as much
snow as Veil and of course I'm here to
try what is famous for
oh my gosh
it's loving it's just an unbelievable
amount of powdery snow I even got caught
up in a blizzard luckily making my way
out
tourists from all around the world flock
here to get a feel of this champagne
powder for themselves
the talk about niseko gets the most snow
in the world so this has been on our
bucket list
we started coming maybe five years ago
it's nice to get a bluebird day there's
not many of those in the Seco normally
there's a
there's a lot of snow and it's very cold
[Music]
the kind of snow ideal for skiing and
snowboarding needs to be dry and Airy
and where nisiko is located is just
perfect for that it's in between the Sea
of Japan and Russia the cold Siberian
wind meets the warm air resulting in
heavy snowfall and hokkaido's
temperature which dips below negative 4
degrees Celsius allows the snow to have
over 90 percent of Trapped air creating
that fluffy powder that snow goers love
after a long day of skiing what better
way to unwind than to come here for some
r r zaborin is a twelve hundred dollar a
night dokang Hotel nestled in the
mountains
is a traditional Japanese style Inn that
typically has an Onsen tatami floors and
dining
and during this space is a whole
experience in itself and you immediately
feel at peace
[Music]
captain
um
all 15 Villas look out at Mount
nyotai and the surrounding areas
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
so you can really feel the nature all
year round yay sorry around always enjoy
that nature
we got a taste of the best from an area
where rich marine ecosystems allow for
some of Japan's most coveted sushi for
that it's time to hit the streets of
Sapporo hokkaido's Capital the hustle
and bustle starts in the wee hours of
the morning at the fish markets Sapporo
is the epicenter when it comes to
seafood and you can find the freshest
catch from all over the island there's
the famous nijo ichiba that's been
around for over a hundred years
if you're a tourist you'd probably come
here but the pros the sushi chefs head
over to suzukino Fish Market
I'm tagging along with Chef masaki on a
shopping run who has been making sushi
for 35 years
oh my gosh this is so much fish
oh hi
um
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is good so I learned something new
this is how you tell if it's a fresh
fish
good oh like this yeah okay so this is
flimsy Fish Fresh and if it's not fresh
it looks like this
yes yes
[Music]
I can't wait to try all right
look at us
[Music]
the Hokkaido I saw was full of nature
pride and amazing energy and that's what
Hokkaido is famous for
[Music]